[Music]
when you're in college future seems like
years away but time flies very quickly
and you graduate
and you enter the real world with very
less idea what to do next believe me i
was in the same situation a year ago
but things have changed very quickly for
me i have joined a company recently and
i'm very happy with it and i think this
is because i of my decision at
upskilling with central
hi i'm sanjo i'm 22 years old i was
supposed to graduate last year in april
but due to the pandemic uh my exams
rotated almost for eight months and it's
a huge gap so i didn't wanted to waste
any of my time the log room for me was a
great span of time i not only completed
my data science projects or courses but
also i upgraded myself in my artworks
and my art skills after completing my
graduation i thought that my resume was
not good enough or it was not strong
enough to get me my dream job so i was
looking for a certification so while
researching about the certification of
data science i found about cinderella i
went through their course structures and
i was amazed like they were also
providing job assist program to me so i
decided to go with sampling so simpler
not only provides you a comprehensive
data science course but it also provides
you help so you can reach your final
goal that is to achieve a job in a
repair company
as you can see the entire content of the
course was on point and it covers a
large number of technologies
i genuinely believe that this course is
a job ready program it doesn't matter if
you are a fresh rep or you have a lot of
experience you can still go for this
course your ambition is as important as
anyone else so keep working on it invest
in yourself allow yourself to grow
because your ambitions cannot be locked
down
[Music]
you